it's always different because each
project is unique and for this one for
example rest on bone I started the the
what I usually do even though it's not a
method it's that I really want to work
before the shooting and I need sometimes
most of the time is like three months of
research of you know when you meet
someone and you want to know who this
person is
I never see something as hard even
though sometimes it is but because I
have this period of time where I will be
able to explore to experience to work so
I never see anything as a challenge I
see kind of a goal and my goal is
authenticity
and I will do whatever it takes to reach
this authenticity my advice would be
experiment work explore explore the more
you can you know take risks and but work
work work that's that would be my advice
I never dreamt of doing American movies
but it was like I never dreamt to do
French movies I just wanted to do movies
and I wanted to tell great stories and
have great roles so I guess because I I
never saw any boundaries that's part of
how it happened and I feel my god I feel
so lucky because American cinema is part
of my of my culture of my generation
culture in France and most of the movies
I watched and I loved when I was a kid
were American so I feel very lucky